So we were talking last time about the
Deuteronomistic historian and their
interpretation of the
events that befell Israel,
a very special interpretation that would
make it possible for Israel to remain
intact after the destruction of the state,
the temple in the national basis of,
of their society. And according to the
Deuteronomist, it's the sin of idolatry,
specifically the sin of idolatry and
particularly the idolatry of the king for
which the nation is punished
with exile and destruction.
Punishments come for other sorts of sins,
but the national punishment of exile and
destruction follows upon the idolatry
and particularly the idolatry of the king.
So in the book of Second Kings,
a king who permits sacrifice only
at the Jerusalem temple is praise,
no matter what other faults
he may or may not have. Um,
and one who does not is condemned no
matter what other accomplishments he may
have to his credit.
Now,
the Deuteronomistic historian is aware
that the historical record doesn't lend
itself very easily to this kind of
interpretation because there are some good
kings who reigned very briefly and there
are some very bad kings on their view
who reigned for a very long time.
And now she has a case in point.
He reigned for over 50 years and is
viewed as the most wicked of all kings.
Sometimes disaster would strike right
after the rule of the king that the
deuteronomist would view as a good king
because of their faithfulness to way.
And sometimes, uh, uh, it,
it would not strike after the rule of a,
of a king that was
viewed to be very wicked.
So the Deuteronomistic sounds
the theme of delayed punishment,
delayed punishment, deferred
punishment. So for example,
Solomon's misdeeds in allowing
the building of altars
for the worship of foreign
gods to please his,
his many wives is foreign wives is
blamed for the division of the kingdoms,
but the punishment was deferred until
after his death and the time of his sons.
And then you have the split between north
and south with Jeroboam and Rehoboam,
um, raining respectively
in the north and south.
The deuteronomist sees Israel's defeat
at the hands of the Assyrians in seven 22
as deferred or delayed punishment for
the sins of Jeroboam. The first Jeroboam,
the first nine 22 or so,
came to the throne and installed to
cultic centers at Dan and Bethel erecting
golden calves.
Uh,
this is seen as a sin for which the
nation was punished 200 years later.
As for the southern Kingdom of Judah,
he had some good kings in the view of
the deuteronomist in the south has a Kia.
He's judged to be a good king.
He instituted sweeping reforms and got
rid of idolatrous altars and manage to
maintain Judas independence against
the Assyrians. But his son, Manasseh,
who reigned for a large part
of the seventh century is
viewed as extraordinarily
wicked. He turned the Jerusalem temple
into a, um, a pagan temple and, uh,
it was a time of, of, uh, great
misery for those who are loyal to,
to Yaffe way time of great terror.
And yet he reigned a long time.
His eight year old grandson,
Josiah, uh, came to the throne in a,
upon his death sometime
probably in the six thirties.
And the Deuteronomistic
views Josiah as a good king.
We've already heard about the story which
is reported in second kings chapter 22
of the refurbishing of the temple,
which happens when he's
about 25 or 26 years old,
discovers a book of the law,
reads it,
and is distressed because it's
terms are not being fulfilled.
And so Josiah orders the abolition
of outlying altars and Pagan Colts.
He brings all of the priests to Jerusalem
and centralizes all worship there in
Jerusalem. Uh, so in
the deuteronomist view,
Josiah is believed to be very good
king for purging the country of these
idolatrous rights and
centralizing worship.
But the thin of Monash IA was too
great and it had to be punished.
So I profit tests a profit tests named
Holda tells desire that God plans to
bring evil punishment on Judah for it,
for these sins.
But it will be after Josiah is lifetime
as, as something of a mercy to him.
And in fact, it's in the next
generation that Judah falls in five 86,
the walls of Jerusalem are breached and
the temple is destroyed and the king at
that time, King Zedekiah
is blinded and, uh,
taken in chains into exile with his
court and only the poor are left behind.
This is the deuteronomist attempt to
account for these anomalies within their
Historia sophic view,
right?
And the result of the Deuteronomistic
interpretation was remarkable because if
the defeat of the nation where to be
seen as the defeat of the nations,
God by the God of the conquering nation,
then the Israelites would have turned
from the worship of their god, Yahweh,
and embraced the new ascendent God Marduk.
And undoubtedly there were
Israelites who did do this, right?
That would have been the argument
of history in their view,
but not all did for some defeat,
did not lead to despair or apostasy
because it could be explained by the likes
of the Deuteronomistic,
a historian or the Deuteronomistic
school as fitting into the monotheistic
scheme,
right?
This did not impugn God's kingship
or Lordship over the universe.
It was proof of it. God was punishing
Israel for the sin of idolatry,
which was in violation of his
covenant and to punish Israel.
He had raised the Babylonians.
They were merely his tool.
The historiography of the Deuteronomistic
historian finds its classic expression
in second kings chapter 17.
Um,
I'm going to skim through sections of it
so you can see the argument that's laid
out there. In the ninth year of Jose,
the king of Assyria captured some area,
the capital of the northern kingdom.
He deported the Israelites,
the Israelites to Syria and
settled them in various places.
And this happened because the
Israelites sinned against the Lord,
their God who had freed them from the
land of Egypt, from the hand of Pharaoh,
King of Egypt.
They worshiped other gods,
followed the customs which the kings
of Israel had practiced, putting again,
the blame and the kings as the,
as the head of this idolatry,
the Israelites committed against the
Lord their God acts which were not right.
They built for themselves shrines and
all their settlements from watchtowers to
fortified cities.
They set up pillars and sacred posts
for themselves on every lofty hill and
under every leafy tree,
and they offered sacrifices there at all
the shrines like the nation's whom the
Lord had driven into exile before them.
So now he's going to follow through since
they behave the same way to drive them
into exile.
Also,
they committed wicked acts to vex
the Lord and they worshiped fetishes
concerning which the Lord had said
to them, you must not do this thing.
The Lord warned Israel and Judah
by every profit in every sear.
So God didn't just stand by idly.
He was constantly sending profits,
messengers to tell them to turn back
to the covenant and we'll start talking
about those profits today.
He sent warnings by every prophet
and every senior are saying,
turn back from your wicked ways and
observe my commandments and my laws
according to all the teaching that
I commanded your fathers and that I
transmitted to you through my servants,
the prophets. But they didn't obey.
They stiffen their neck.
It's like their fathers who did not
have faith in the Lord their God.
They spurned his laws and the covenant
that he had made with their fathers and
the warnings he had given them. They
went after delusion and we're diluted.
They made Moulton idols for themselves.
Two calves,
the specifically now the sin of, of
Jeroboam at Dan and Bethel, two calves,
and they made a sacred post and they
bowed down to all the hosts of heaven and
they worshiped by aisle.
We'll hear more about that today.
They can sign their sons
and daughters to the fire.
They practiced augury and divination
and gave themselves over to what was
displeasing to the Lord and Vex Tim.
The Lord was incensed it Israel,
and he banished them from his presence.
None was left with the
tribe of Judah alone,
but nor did Judah keep the
commandments of the Lord their God.
They followed the customs
that Israel had practiced,
so the Lord spurned all the offspring
of Israel and he afflicted them and
delivered them into the
hands of plunderers and
finally he cast them out from
his presence.
It's a very depressing ending of things
that started so auspiciously back in
genesis one.
But if the Deuteronomy,
this laid the blame for the tragic
history of the two kingdoms at the door of
the sin of idolatry, in particularly
the idolatry of the royal house,
a different answer will be provided
by Israel's classical profits.
No less than answer,
no lesson interpretation and the lesson
interpretation that was intended to
shore up faith in this God that one
might think had abandoned his people.
And we'll be turning to the
prophetic answer to this,
to this great crisis
that face the Israelites.
In the next lecture in this lecture,
I first want to talk about the phenomenon
of prophecy and some of the profits
who appear in the historical narrative.
So in the historical books that we've
been looking at of the section of the
Bible, we call the former prophets.
Remember this section called the profits.
We divide into former
prophets ladder profits.
The section we call former
profits as a historical narrative.
It runs from Joshua through second kings.
It reads like a narrative.
And in that material,
you have several prophets who appear and
they play a very role in the national
drama,
the profits of the 10th century,
the Ninth Century BCE.
We're associated with religious shrines.
On occasion they were
associated with the royal court.
But starting in about the eighth century,
you have profits whose words were
eventually sat down and writing,
and they come to be in the books that
now bear the names of the profits to whom
they are attributed. Um, so these profits,
the ones whose words get recorded
in books that bear their name,
these profits we call the literary profits
or the classical prophets in contrast
to the prophets who are characters in
the stories that we read from Genesis
through second kings, right? So
there are two kinds of profits. Um,
the literary profits,
those books are collected together.
In the section we call the latter
prophets. I hope this is making sense.
So former profits is the historical
narrative which happens to feature king's
and profits as characters in the
narrative, the latter profits.
Those are the books of Prophetic oracles
that bear the name of the person who
gave the utterance or the
Oracle. Okay. And as I just said,
the literary profits just like the
deuteronomist struggle to make sense of
Israel suffering and defeat and to come
up with an explanation and a message of
constellation and we will
get to that next time.
Today we'll look at the phenomenon of
prophecy in ancient Israel by comparing or
examining narratives in Samuel and kings,
particularly narratives that feature
profits and that will provide very
important background for the next
lecture when we turn to the books of the
literary or classical prophets
and the themes of that literature.
Now prophecy is very widespread
in the ancient near east.
It took different forms in different
societies, but ultimately very widespread.
We know of ecstatic profits
from second Millennium Bce,
texts in Mesopotamia.
Um,
seventh century is Syria
also have ecstatic profits.
Their primary focus was on,
um,
delivering oracles for kings.
Usually favorable was always wise to
give a favorable oracle to your king.
Um, and we have ecstatic prophecy in the
Bible also among the earliest profits.
In particular,
the term ecstasy when it's used in this
context refers to the state of being
overcome with such powerful emotions.
That reason seems to be suspended.
Self control is suspended. What
we might think of as, you know,
normative behavior, these things,
normal behavior, these are suspended.
Ecstatics would employ music
and dance. They would, um,
they would induce a sort of emotional
seizure or a frenzy and they would often
be left riving and raving.
And the Bible attributes this kind of
ecstatic state to the spirit of the Lord.
The spirit of Galloway which falls upon
a profit or Russia's upon a prophet
comes upon a profit and transforms
him then into some sort of carrier or
instrument of the divine
will or the divine message.
We'll see that we have bizarre
behavior among many of the profits.
We even have bizarre behavior among
many of the later literary profits. Um,
Zko for example, we'll engage in
all kinds of unusual, outrageous,
dramatic behavior as a vehicle for
the communication of his message.
And I think this is the heritage of the
ecstatic prophecy that was so much a
part of ancient near east and prophecy.
But not all.
Biblical prophecy has
this ecstatic character.
The Hebrew word for profit is a Navi.
And then the word [inaudible]
seems to mean one who is called,
or perhaps one who announces that's
important because it signals to us that a
prophet is someone who is
called to proclaim a message,
to announce something called
by God to carry a message.
And so in the Bible we have
this phenomenon of what we
call epistolic prophecy.
And Apostle is merely a messenger.
The word apostle means messenger
one sent with a message.
So at Apostolic Prophecy,
this refers to messenger profits.
They are called by God and
charged with a mission.
They can even be elected
against their will.
They must bring the word
of God to the world.
This is very different from profits
who are consulted by a client, right?
And given a fee to divine something,
this is different.
This is the deity. Now charging
a profit with a message, uh, to,
to a people.
So these epistolic profits are represented
in the Bible as the instrument of
God's desire to reveal himself and
to reveal his will to his people.
And many scholars have
noted that in a way. Um,
Moses is really the first in a long
line of apostolic prophets in the Bible.
And in some ways his
call and his response,
our parodic matic for some of
these later classical prophets,
in many of the literary
profits you will read,
they will contain some account
of their call, you know,
have this sudden dramatic
encounter with God.
Usually the call consists of certain,
um, uh, standard, uh, stages.
You first have this
unexpected encounter with God,
maybe a vision of some kind or a voice,
um,
that issues in a summons or a calling.
And then you have the
reluctance of the individual.
And that was also paradigmatic with Moses,
wasn't it the,
the reluctance of the individual
concerned to answer this,
but ultimately the individual is
overwhelmed and eventually surrenders to,
to God and his persuasiveness. That
happens in many of the prophetic books.
So in the Bible,
this kind of epistolic prophecy is a
little different from ecstatic prophecy.
It's also distinct from divination.
Divination is an attempt to
uncover the divine through some,
um, technique or excuse me, the
divine will through some technique,
perhaps the manipulation
of certain substances,
perhaps inspecting the end trails
of a sacrificed animal. Um,
divination of this type as well as sorcery
and spell casting and consulting with
ghosts and spirits are all
condemned by Deuteronomy.
This is very important part of the
Deuteronomistic diatribe against the
practices of other nations,
but the fact that Deuteronomy polemicizing
so vehemently against these practices
is a sure sign that they were practiced.
You know,
they were practiced at a popular level.
This is probably what is related.
Judy and religion consisted of to some
degree and some of you will be looking in
section,
I know at the story of the witch of endor,
right when Saul goes to a witch to conjure
up the spirit of the ghost to Samuel
to, to consult with him. Um,
moreover we do have divination
in the outweigh cult itself,
but this was performed by priests.
They consulted some sort of divinely,
um,
designated or Rachid
[inaudible] object or objects.
We call these the RM and the term him,
which should be familiar
to all of you here at Yale,
but [inaudible] are usually untranslated
in your texts because actually we don't
really know what they mean. They might be
related to the word for light, which is,
or, and the, the word for, um, you
know, integrity perhaps or perfection,
which is Tom. So it might be, it's
probably something like Abracadabra,
a little bit of a nonsense syllable that
plays on words that did have meaning.
We don't really know what
the ORM and tuning word,
but they are said to be assigned by God.
We think they may have been colored stones
that were manipulated in some way by
the priest to give a yes or a
no determination to a question.
But these are said to be assigned by God
as a means that he himself authorizes
for defining his will. And so the
Deuteronomistic steps accepts these,
but in general it's the view of the
Deuteronomistic historian that divination
sorcery and the like
are not only prohibited,
they're quite distinct from
the activity of profits.
That's not what the profits were about.
According to the Deuteronomistic
a representation,
the Hebrew prophet wasn't primarily a
fortune teller and I think this is a very
common misconception.
The Navi,
the Prophet was addressing a very
specific historical situation and was
addressing it in very concrete terms.
He was revealing God's immediate
intentions as a response to the present
circumstances.
And the purpose of doing this was
to inspire the people to change, to,
to come back to faithful
observance of the covenant.
Any predictions that the profit might
make had reference to the immediate future
as a response to the present situation.
So in reality,
the profits message was a message
about the present. What is wrong now?
What has to be done to avert the
impending doom or two n to avert a future
calamity. There were some
women prophets in Israel, um,
none of them are found
among the literary profits.
That is to say none of those books bearing
the names of the prophets who uttered
the oracles in them are named for women.
So we have no women among
the literary profits,
but you do have prophetic or prophesizing
women besides Miriam and the pen to
Tuk.
There's also Debra who was a tribal leader
and a profit featured in judges four
and five.
I mentioned Holda.
Her advice is sought during the reign of
King Josiah and you also have no idea,
no idea prophesied in
the post exit periods.
So this doesn't seem to
be limited to two males.
Prophecy and kingship are
closely connected in ancient
Israel and this is going
to be very important.
You'll recall first of all,
that the king is the anointed
one of Yahweh and it's the
prophet who's doing the
anointing.
And that makes the connection between
kingship and prophecy quite strong.
If you think about
Israel's first two kings,
you also see a strong link with
the phenomenon of prophecy.
The first King Saul who was anointed
by the Prophet Samuel is in addition,
said to have prophesied himself in the
manner of the ecstatic profits. Um,
when he is anointed king,
he's then seized by the spirit of Yahweh.
He joins a band of men. And this
is in First Samuel 10, verse five,
there playing Harp, tambourine,
flute and liar. And he joins them.
And this induces a,
an ecstatic frenzy or religious frenzy
that transforms him into another man
according to the text. And on another
occasion, during his ecstatic prophesying,
Saul strips himself naked.
We have other accounts in the Bible of
ecstatic prophets who would engage in
self laceration.
David,
the second king is also
said to prophesize himself.
He also receives the Holy Spirit
or charisma from time to time,
in addition to being
anointed by a prophet.
Subsequent monarchs aren't
said to prophesied themselves.
So that ends really with David.
It's only Saul and David who are
among the prophets. But um, even so,
those subsequent profits do not.
The monarchs do not themselves prophesied.
The connection with prophecy remains very,
very close and it's exemplified
in several ways. Again,
profits not only anoint kings, but they
also announced their fall from power,
right? They are king makers and
king breakers to some degree. Also,
you have a remarkable motif that runs
through so much of biblical narrative.
And that's the Motif of
prophetic opposition to kings.
Every king had his prophetic thorn
in his side. So you have, uh,
Samuel against saw, right?
You have Nathan against King.
David will talk about him a bit later. You
have other prophets, Elijah, of course,
against Ahab.
My Kia against Ahab Have Alicia
against the House of Ahab. Um,
Jeremiah is going to a soup
stand against the king, uh,
quite the quite dramatically. So that
prophetic opposition to the monarch,
to the king,
sort of God's watchdog over the king
is an important theme throughout the
stories of the form of profits,
right?
It sets and it sets a stage for us to
understand the writings of the named
profits that will come later.
Those are very often given in opposition
to official policy or royal policy.
And very often you have
this sort of literary motif
that introduces the profits.
Opposition.
The word of the Lord came to x,
profit x against why? Against King, why?
And then you get the content of it because
you have sinned. I will destroy you.
I will rest of the kingship
from you and so on.
So I want to take a quick look though
at some of the roles that are played by
profits in the stories and Samuel and
kings and I have them listed over on the
far side of the board. The first thing
I want to consider is the notion of um,
what I call yes men.
Um,
as opposed to true profits
like the kings of Assyria,
the kings of Israel and Judah found
it politic to employ prophetic gilts.
And in many cases,
these court prophets who were in the
king's employ were little more than
endorsers of royal policy.
So on numerous occasions we
see these professional profits,
these royal profits at odds with figures
that the biblical writer will view as
true profits.
They are truly for claiming the word of
God and not just endorsing royal policy.
And they proclaim it whether the
king wants to hear it or not,
whether the people want to hear it or not.
And the classic example is my Kale,
the son of Emma.
My Kia prophesies the truth from your way,
even though it displeases the king and
ultimately is going to cost him his
freedom. I'm not to be confused
with Micah, my chaos. Uh,
his story is told in first kings 22.
Uh,
this story is, um, uh, pointed
critique of the prophetic.
Yes men who are serving as court profits
for and automatically endorse the
policy of King Ahab.
He's the king in the northern Kingdom
of Israel in the ninth century.
And during King Ahab Rain,
the kingdoms of the north and the south
of Israel and Judah have decided to form
an alliance.
They want to try to recapture some of
the territory that has been lost to the
north territory in Syria.
But you didn't undertake any military
expedition without first obtaining a
favorable word from the Lord.
So King Ahab's profits and he has 400
of them and they're called and the king
asks them,
shall I?
March upon remote Gilliad this is
this region in the north for battle,
or shall I not?
March they said,
and the Lord will deliver it
into Your Majesty's hands.
So we see that prophecy
here is an institution,
it's functioning as a
source of royal advice,
but the king of Judah Kings Jehoshaphat's,
he had been perhaps hoping for an
oracle against the campaign and he says,
isn't there another prophet of the
Lord here through whom we can inquire?
And the king of Israel
answered Jehoshaphat's there
is one more man through whom
we can inquire of the Lord,
but I hate him because he never prophesies
anything about me. Only disaster.
My Kia son of [inaudible],
well Jehoshaphat insists and my Kia is
summit and he's worn by the Messenger who
summons him that he better
speak a favorable word like
all the other prophets.
The Messenger says the words of the
prophets with one accord are favorable to
the king. Let your word be like the
word of one of them and speak favorably.
It's almost an open admission that the
profits are in a little more than yes men.
So my Kia answers the king's question
when he asks about the advisability of
marching to the north and he says,
March and triumph,
the Lord will deliver it
into Your Majesty's hands.
He's done what he's been told to do, give
the same answer as the other prophets.
But he doesn't use the prophetic formula.
He doesn't say,
thus says the Lord or some
other indication that he's
had a vision that he's
prophesying that is actually
conveying the word of the Lord.
And the king seems to sense this. And
since this deception, and he says,
how many times must die Jura you to tell
me nothing but the truth in the name of
the Lord. So my Kale, it's the king habit.
And he tells of this vision
that he received from God,
a vision of Israel scattered among
of, sorry, of, of, of, of uh,
of Israel scattered over hills like
sheep. So he's seeing sheep, right?
Without a shepherd.
The implication being that Israel's
Sheppard who was the king is going to be
killed in battle. And like
the sheep spread on the hill,
Israel will be scattered.
So the king is very irritated
by my k is prophecy. He says,
didn't I tell you he would not
prophesied good fortune for me,
but only misfortune.
What's interesting is in the
section that follows my k,
it gives an explanation for
why he is the lone dissenter.
He doesn't accuse the other
profits of being false prophets.
He represents them instead as being
misled and is being misled by God if you
will. So for the second time my
Kia utters the word of the Lord.
He has a second vision and this vision
is a vision of God who is seated on the
throne and the host of heaven are
gathered around him and God asks,
who will entice Ahab so that he will
march and fall at Ramos Gilliad and a
certain one, uh, comes forward.
He volunteers for this task and he tells
me how he's going to do this. He says,
I will go out and be a lying spirit
in the mouth of all his prophets.
God says, you will entice and you
will prevail. Go out and do it.
So my Kia concludes this vision by saying,
and so the Lord has put a lying spirit
in the mouth of all these profits of
yours. For the Lord has decreed disaster
upon you. It's all part of God's plan.
God is setting up a hub for disaster,
presumably as punishment
for his many sins. Justice.
He set up pharaoh by hardening his heart
so that he would be punished. Um, and uh,
hardening his heart against Moses is
pleased to let these are lights go.
This is God's way of ensuring their
demise, ensuring their punishment.
Kings a little upset.
He doesn't know whom to believe.
So he doesn't kill my Kia on the spot.
He imprisons him,
he puts them on rations
of bread and water. Um,
just to see what the outcome
of the battle will be first.
And my k agrees to this.
He says,
if you ever come home safe and the
Lord has not spoken through me,
his prophecy proves
accurate. Of course. Um,
the king tries to disguise himself so
that no one will know that he is king and
no one will be able to target him in
the battle. So he disguises himself.
Nevertheless, he's killed in the
battle and his army scatters.
The story of my Kia is polemicizing
against what the biblical writer perceived
to be the nationalization or the
cooptation of the prophetic guild.
And in the process it paints a
portrait of what the true profit, uh,
looks like.
My Kia is someone who is
determined to deliver God's word,
even if it's opposed to, um, the,
the wishes of the king or the view of
the king and the view of the majority.
He's going to proclaim God's judgment
and it will be a judgment against the
nation. It will be a message of
doom. And interestingly enough,
this will eventually become understood
as the mark of a true prophet.
The prophet of doom is the one who is
the true profit. Um, as you can imagine,
this kind of negativity, and it didn't
sit well with established interests,
but at a later point in time,
looking back,
the tradition would single out some of
these profits as the ones who had spoken
truly. So that's one role. The
true profit stands up against the,
the Prophetic Gilds, the prophets who are
employed by the Kings, um, by the kings.
A second role that we see profits
playing in this section of historical
narrative.
We see profits as God's zealots.
And here again, there's a contrast
between true prophets and false prophets.
You find it particularly in those zealous,
Yahweh's Elijah and Elijah.
The Elijah stories are found in first
kings chapter 17 through 19 and 21 first
kings 17 through 19 and 21.
The Elijah stories appear towards
the beginning of second kings,
chapters two through nine a
little bit in a chapter 13.
These materials are good examples,
again of independent units of tradition,
popular stories that were incorporated
into the Deuteronomistic history.
They're highly folkloristic.
They have lots of drama and color,
plenty of miracles.
Animals who behave in interesting ways
that this material began as a set of folk
stories is also suggested by the fact
that there's a great deal of overlap in
the depiction of the
activities of the two profits.
So you have both of the profits.
I'm multiplying food.
Both of them predict the death of
Ahab's, queen, Queen Jezza Bell,
both of them part water and so on.
But in their final form,
the stories have been interspersed with
historical footnotes about two profits
and then set into this framework,
this larger framework of the history
of the kings of the northern kingdom.
So they've been appropriated
by the Deuteronomistic school,
which remember is a southern Judy
and based Deuteronomistic school. Um,
they've been appropriated for
its purposes, which include, um,
a strong condemnation of the northern
kingdom of Israel and, and her kings as,
as idolatrous. So Elijah,
Elijah the Tishbite,
which means that he comes from
the city of Tish Bay in Gilliad,
which is the other side of the Jordan.
Elijah is a very dramatic character.
He comes across the Jordan,
he's dressed in a garment of
hair and the leather girdle.
At the end of his story, he's sort of
whisked away. One of the king's servants,
surmises by the wind of God.
He does battle with the
cult of Baal and Asherah.
We Associate Alijah most with the battle
with the cult of bile and ashy raw.
This had been introduced by King Ahab
to please his bow. We're shipping queen,
Queen Jezza bow.
And as his first act,
Alijah announces a draft. Yeah, announces
a drought in the name of Yaffe way.
Now this is a direct challenge to bow
because bio is believed to control the
rain.
He's believed to control the general
fertility of the land and and life itself.
So ally just purpose is presumably to
show that it is your way and not by all
who controls fertility.
We have very good evidence that bow
was in fact worshiped in the northern
kingdom,
right down to the destruction.
This is something we've
touched on earlier as well.
It's quite possible that Israelites in
the northern kingdom saw no real conflict
between the cult of bile
and the cult of [inaudible].
But in the Elijah story,
the Deuteronomistic historian represents
these two cults as being championed by
exclusivist.
It's one or the other.
Jessebelle Ahab's queen kept a retinue
of 450 by all profits and was killing off
the profits of Galloway,
right? And by the same token,
Elijah is equally zealous for Galloway.
He refuses to tolerate the worship
of any God but Yaffe way. Um,
and he performs miracles constantly in
the name of your way to show that it is
yeah, halfway and not bow who
gives life. For example, he, um,
he raises a dead child.
He multiplies oil and flour and so on
all of this in the name of the Lord to
show that it is your way and not
by al who has true power. Um,
but as I've mentioned
before, there are some, um,
some scholars who argue that biblical
religion, again as opposed to Israelite,
Judy and religion, what actual people
were doing in Israel and Judea.
That's one thing. But Biblical religion,
which is this exclusive, I'm yeah,
wisdom or the tendency towards monotheism.
There are some who believe that that
biblical religion originated in the
activity of zealous prophets like Elijah
and Elisha in the north doing battle
with the, with the bout with bile worship.
Um, after the fall of the kingdom,
those traditions,
those Yahweh only traditions came south
and were eventually absorbed in the
Deuteronomistic school. So this
in fact, maybe the origin of, of,
of some of this is this Jaqui only party
represented by figures like Elijah and
Elisha.
The conflict between the two cults,
the outweigh cult and the bowel called
reaches a climax in the story in first
kings 18 is wonderful story in which,
uh,
Elijah challenges the prophets of
Baal and Asherah to it contest.
We have to remember that a severe drought
has fallen on the land which Alijah
attributes to God's punishment for
Ahab's sin in introducing by worship on,
on a broad scale.
Now,
Elijah is hiding from the king who's
very angry with him for declaring this
drought in the name of God. After
three years, he returns to Ahab.
Ahab sees Elijah and he says, is
that you, you troubler of Israel?
And the profit responds. It is not I
who have brought trouble on Israel,
but you and your father's house by
forsaking the commandments of the Lord.
And going after the bowels now summoned
all Israel to join me at Mount Carmel
together with the 450 prophets of Baal
and the 400 prophets of our ra who eat at
Jezza bells table that are
supported by the royal house. Uh,
when all of these people are gathered,
Elijah challenges the Israelites, he says,
how long will you keep hopping between
two opinions? If the Lord is God,
follow him. And if by I'll follow him,
you're hopping between two opinions.
So it seems that at the popular level,
there's no problem with
integrating these two cults,
but you have the profits of both that
are demanding a certain exclusivism.
He's met with silence.
So Elijah prepares for a
dramatic context contest.
Two bowls are slaughtered and
they are laid on altars. One,
an altar to Baal and one
an altar to [inaudible].
And the 450 prophets of Baal
are to invoke their god.
And Elijah will invoke his God to
send a fire to consume the sacrifice.
And the God who answers first,
or the God who answers
with fire is truly God.
So the Baal prophets invoke their God
a morning to noon and they're shouting,
Oba, I'll answer us. And the description
that follows is wonderfully satirical,
but there was no sound
and none who responded.
So they performed a hopping dance about
the alter that had been set up when noon
came. Alijah mocked them saying
shout louder after all he is a god,
but he may be in conversation or he may
be relieving himself in the bathroom or
he may be on a journey or perhaps
he's asleep and we'll wake up.
So they shouted louder and Gash
themselves with knives and spears, uh,
according to their practice until
the blood streamed over them.
And when noon past,
they kept raving until the hour
of presenting the meal offering.
So more hours have gone by and still
there's no sound and nun who responded are
heated.
And then it's Elijah's turn.
Elijah sets up 12 stones
to represent the 12 tribes.
He lays the bull out on the altar.
He then digs a trench around the alter,
any orders,
water to be poured over the whole thing
so that it's completely saturated in the
trenches,
filled with water.
This is going to highlight of course
the miracle that's about to occur.
And then he calls upon the name of the
Lord and instantly a fire descends from
God and consumes everything.
Offering Woodstone earth, water,
everything and the people prostrate
themselves and declare. Yeah,
way alone is God.
Yahweh alone is God.
The prophets of Baal are
all seized and slaughtered.
Alijah expects an end to the drought and
a servant comes to report to him that a
cloud as small as a man's hand is rising
in the west and the sky grows black and
there's a strong wind and a heavy
storm and the drought is finally over.
The language that's used to describe this
storm is the language that's typically
employed for the storm God bow.
Um,
it drives home the point of
the whole satire that yeah,
way is the real god of the storm, not
by Ollie. Galloway controls nature,
not by aisle. It's God who's effective
by all is silent and powerless.
And Israel's choice should be clear.
Yeah.
We should be the only God for Israel just
as he is for Alijah whose name Eliyahu
means. My God. Illy my God is Yahweh.
So Jessebelle is pretty upset and
she threatens Alijah with execution.
So he flees into the desert and he
will spend 40 days and 40 nights at a
mountain called Horeb or Sinai.
That of course is the site
of God's revelation to Moses.
Moses also spent 40 days and 40 nights
there and many scholars have pointed out
the numerous parallels
between Elijah and Moses.
It seems that I'm the writer.
Um,
there was a conscious literary shaping
of the Elijah Traditions on the model of
Moses and in more ways than just
these two. We'll see a few coming up.
Elijah is in great despair that Sinai,
he wants to die.
He feels that he has failed in his fight
for God and so he hides himself in a,
in a rocky cleft and this is also
reminiscent of the cleft that Moses hides
himself in in order to catch a
glimpse of God has God passes by. Um,
similarly,
Alijah hides in a cleft where he will
encounter God as passages in first kings
19 verses nine through 12.
Then the word of the Lord came to him.
He said to him, why are you here Elijah?
He replied,
I am moved by zeal for the Lord.
The God of hosts for the Israelites
have forsaken your covenant,
Torn Down Your Altars and put
your prophets to the sword.
I alone am left and they are
out to take my life. Come out.
He called and stand on the mountain before
the Lord and low. The Lord passed by.
There was a great and mighty
wind splitting mountains
and shattering rocks by
the power of the Lord.
But the Lord was not in the wind
after the wind and earthquake,
but the Lord was in the earthquake
after the earthquake fire.
But the Lord was not in the
fire and after the fire,
a soft murmuring sound or
perhaps it's still small voice,
a lot of translations use that phrase,
which is very poetic.
And when Elijah heard it, he wrapped
his mantle about his face and went out.
It stood and stood at
the entrance of the cave,
so I just seems to be renewed somehow.
At Sinai,
this was the mountain that was a
source of Israel's covenant with God,
but whereas the earlier theophanous there
at Sinai had involved earthquake and
wind and fire.
The narrative here seems to be making a
point of saying that God is not in the
earthquake and the wind and the fire.
He's in the lull after the storm.
This might then be providing a kind of
balance or corrective to the preceding
story that we've just had of Mount Carmel.
Elijah on Mount Carmel.
God may be the master of the storm and
Elijah dramatically demonstrated that,
but he isn't to be identified with the
storm in the same way that bow was.
He's not a nature God and
he's known only in silence,
kind of awesome vocal
silence in the theophany.
Then that follows to Elijah.
God Instructs Elijah to return.
He has to leave Sinai. He has to be
turned to the people he has work to do.
He has to foment rebellion or revolution,
I should say in the royal house.
This task is one that Elijah
will not complete his disciple.
Elisha will end up completing it.
But the importance in this scene I think
is its emphasis on God as the God of
history rather than a nature God.
Israel's God acts in history. He's been,
he's made known to humans
by his acts in history.
His Prophet cannot withdraw
to a mountain retreat.
He has to return and he has to play
his part in God's plans for the nation.
So we've discussed the
prophet as gods zealots.
It's particularly as illustrated or
exemplified by Elijah and Elisha.
The Prophet, uh, also had other
roles and we'll see this in Elijah.
Elijah succeeds Alijah.
Um,
the cycle of stories about Elijah ends
with Elijah's ascent into heaven on a
fiery chariot chariot and a whirlwind.
Um,
that's a detail in the story that has
contributed to the longstanding belief
that Elijah never died. And so Elijah
will be the harbinger of the Messiah.
He will come back to announce that
the coming of the Messiah, um,
Elijah left his prophetic cloak to
his disciple and successor Elijah.
Elijah's involvement in the political
arena was also important and highlights,
um,
another prophetic role we've touched
on before that of king maker and King
Breaker.
So just as Samuel Anointed Saul King
and then David King in private meetings,
you also have Elijah,
he sends an associate to
secretly anoint Jay who Jay,
who is one of Ahab's x
captains as King of Israel.
This is going to initiate a
very bloody civil war. Um,
Jay who's going to massacre all of
Ahab's family, all of his supporters,
his retinue in Israel.
He also assembles all of
the bowel worshipers and a
great temple that was built
by Ahab in some area.
And then he orders all of them
killed and the temple demolished.
So it is a pitched battle, an all out
war between the halfway only party,
the [inaudible] party.
We're not going to be looking
at Elijah in great detail,
but I will just point out one last aspect
of his prophetic profile that I think
is notable here in the book of Kings.
And that is um,
the characteristic of,
of uh,
profits as miracle workers like Elijah.
Elijah performs miracles.
He causes an iron ax to float.
He raises a child from the dead.
He feels jars of oil.
He makes poison soup edible.
He causes 20 loaves of barley to
feed a hundred men and heals lepers.
These legendary stories in which,
um,
divine intentions are effected by means
of the supernatural powers of holy men.
This represents a popular religiosity.
Um, people would turn to wonder,
working holy men when they were sick
or in crisis when they needed help.
And this kind of religious activity,
which was clearly widespread in the
ancient near east in Israel. Um,
this kind of popular belief,
this fascination with
wonder, working charismatics,
it's also seen very prominently in
the gospels of the New Testament.
A final prophetic role is I'm very
well illustrated by the Prophet Nathan.
Nathan is a classic example of a prophet
who serves as the conscience of the
king.
In Second Samuel Chapters 11 and 12,
we have the dramatic story
of David and Bathsheba King.
David's elicit union with Bathsheba.
As you know, she's the wife of Uriah.
He was fighting in the king's army.
Um,
his illicit union with Bathsheba
results in her pregnancy.
And when David learns that
Best Sheba is pregnant,
he first tries to avoid the
issue. He grants Uriah, you know,
a leave from, from the front lines. Um,
he's come on home and have a conjugal
visit with your wife and your Ryan's very
pious leaves you to wonder who knew
what when, um, it's a great story.
It's told with a lot of
subtlety and indirection,
but your eyes very pious and he refuses.
Know How could I enjoy myself
when people are out there dying,
which is an implicit criticism of the
king who just did that very thing. Um,
and so David has foiled there and he
plans to then just dispose of Uriah.
So he orders your eyes,
commanders to place your idea in the
front lines of the battle and then pull
back so that your eye is basically
left on his own and he will be killed.
And indeed he is.
So David ad's murder to adultery,
but not even the king is above God's
law and God sends his Prophet Nathan to
tell the King of fable.
This is in Second Samuel 12 verses one
through 14 there were two men in same
city,
one rich and one poor.
And the rich man had very
large flocks and herds,
but the poor man had only one
little Ewe lamb that he had bought.
He tended it and it grew up
together with him and his children.
It used to share his morsel of bread
and drink from his cup and Nessel in his
bosom.
It was like a daughter to him.
One day a traveler came to the rich man,
but he was loath to take anything from
his own flocks or herds to prepare a meal
for the guest who had come to him.
So he took the poor man's
land and prepared it for
the man who had come to him.
And David flew into a rage against the
man and said to Nathan, as the Lord lives,
the man who did this deserves to die.
He shall pay for the lamb four times over
because he did such a thing and showed
no pity. And Nathan said
to David, that man is you.
It's such a wonderful story and it's,
and it's wonderful to think that
Nathan wasn't struck down on the spot.
Uh, he escaped with his
life after this accusation,
but it's symptomatic of the
biblical narrators view of monarchy,
the subjugation of the king
to Ya'll way to highways,
teachings to you always commandments to
always true profits that we don't hear
that a Nathan is carted off,
but instead David acknowledges
his guilt and he repents.
He doesn't escape all
punishment for this deed.
The child of the Union does in fact die.
Um,
and there's a great deal of future strife
and treachery in David's household as
we know. And the writer does blame
a good deal of that on the deeds.
These terrible sins of David's Alijah
similarly is going to function as the
conscience of King Ahab in First Kings 21.
There you have a story of a vineyard,
the king covets,
this particular vineyard of,
of a particular man.
So the king's wife Jessebelle falsely
accuses the man of blast for me.
That is a capital crime and
the man is stoned to death,
even though these are trumped up charges
and his property is transferred to the
crown.
Shortly after that Alijah appears and
he pronounces doom upon a Ahab and his
descendants, uh, for this terrible
deed, Ahab admits the sin, he repents.
Um, and so his punishment is
delayed. But as we've seen,
he is later killed in battle at
remote Giliad. So in these stories,
we see the prophets functioning
as troubler of Israel. You know,
certainly from the [inaudible],
the royal point of view and their
relationships with the royal house. Um,
these relationships are quite adversarial.
So we're ready to move
into what we call the,
the period of classical prophecy
and the literary profits.
And that's a period that begins
with two prophets, Amos and Hosea,
who we'll be talking about next time.
They,
the last prophet of the
classical prophets was Malakai.
So you have about a 320 year period.
If the prophets prophesied from about
seven 50 down to about four 30 but 320
years, um, that's what's,
that's the span of time covered by
these books of the literary profits.
And these profits were responding to
urgent crises in the life of the nation.
It's,
it's easiest if we think of them as being
grouped around four periods of crisis
or four critical periods,
which I've listed here.
First we have profits of
the Assyrian crisis, right?
I remember the fall of a series
of fall of Israel and seven 22.
So around that clustering,
around that time,
we have profits of the Babylonian crisis,
the destruction of
course there is five 86.
So we have prophets who cluster around
that time a little bit before. Um,
then you have profits of the exile, the
years that are spent in exile in Babylon,
and that's primarily a Zeo.
And then we have profits of the Post
Zelig or restoration community when the
Israelites are allowed to come back
to restore their community. Uh,
and we'll see certain profits there.
So in the eighth century,
the Assyrian Empire is threatening Israel.
And Judah,
you have to northern profits, Amos
and Hosea, the n is for north.
So Amos and Hosea are prophesying
in the north. And then in the, uh,
their warning of this doom,
it's going to come as punishment for
violations of the Mosaic Covenant.
Israel fell in seven 22.
You have a similar threat being posed by
the Assyrians to the southern kingdom,
Judah. And so you have to Judy
and prophets, Isaiah and Micah,
they carry a similar message to the Judy.
And so those four we associate with the
Assyrian crisis with the fall of Nineveh,
the capital of Assyria
that falls in six 12.
And that's something that the
profit not home celebrates.
Then Babylon is the master of the region.
Judah becomes a vassal state,
but tries to rebel and the profits.
Habbakuk and Jeremiah,
they prophesied in the southern
kingdom in Judah. Um, Jeremiah,
he urges political submission to Bab to
Babylon because he sees Babylon as the
agent of God's just punishment.
But we'll come back and look at
all these messages in great detail.
Post exit like profit or exhibit
Prophet Ezekiel, as I said,
a prophet of the exile who's consoling
the people in exile in Babylonia,
but also asserting the justice
of what has happened. Um,
and then finally at the
end of the sixth century,
when the first exile is our
returning to restore the community,
returning to their homeland, they face a
very harsh life. And you have had guys,
Zechariah promising a better future.
You have profits like Joel and Malakai
who brings some ex eschatological hope
into the mix. So that can help frame.
Those are the ones we're gonna touch on.
Mostly. We're not going to hit
all of the prophetic books,
but these are the main ones will hit and
we'll start in with them. Aimless. Uh,
next time.